hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the global chess
League it is round six and it is
yaniponishi versus Magnus Carlsen the
former World Chase Championship Duo uh
of course this world's Championship
beyond the nut face Magnus Magnus
decided not to play he faced the dingler
but still they have faced each other
many many times in different time forms
this is rapid now and of course we've
mentioned already that Magnus Crossing
is even two times World rapid champion
and while uh Yani polishing never
actually won the world rapid
Championship he did get second place
three times and third place one so uh
definitely not a stranger to the format
so let's check it out it's it's a really
a long grueling game you will feel like
you are really watching a game from a
world Choice championship match so let's
check it out nipple has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 Magnus
plays Pawn to C5 going for his Sicilian
Defense and nipple opts for the alapan
variation Pawn to C3 and now you could
play a lot of moves here and a lot of
moves are very very good in this
position D5 and Knight to F6 being just
the top two uh Magnus goes for Pawn to
E5 and this is uh I think it's like the
eighth most popular move so uh I mean
not uh not of beat but uh not something
you would you would play in uh in a
truly serious game uh but he's testing
Jan to see uh you know if he knows his
theory and Jan shows that of course he
does Knight to F3 with Knight to C6
Bishop to C4 and Knight to F6 so now we
have this weird looking position where
uh look at what white played E4 Knight
F3 and Bishop to C4 and black has the
two knights out and the pawn on E5 so
it's basically the two knights defense
with the inclusion of C5 and C3 so what
does this mean uh this means that uh
nipple will just treat it as a two nice
defense so he just goes Knight to G5 and
goes for the df7 pawn and okay Pawn to
D5 with e captures and D5 and now a move
uh you don't really play in the two nice
defense but here Magnus plays it Knight
captures and D5 and in the olden days uh
you've just obliterated everyone with
white I hear you just sacrificed on F7
but nepo doesn't he uh you know he
strongly feels that Magnus is very much
prepared for this because if you capture
and King captures Knight to F3 check now
uh the problem is what happens uh if uh
King to E6 of course the Knight cannot
move the Knight is pinned but if you go
King Day six the game just continues
okay
um yeah you're down a piece but can you
Checkmate the black king well not really
let's say Pawn to D4 B5 now forcing the
bishop off of this diagonal and after B
Bishop captures Bishop to B7 putting the
bishop on this diagonal the game
continues uh White has some initiative
but of course if Magnus is willingly
going into this you know that he's very
much prepared so First Pawn to D4 we
have C captures and D4 and now Queen to
B3 putting pressure on the Knight here
of course if the Knight moves then you
just get obliterated here and of course
putting pressure on B7 if the light
square of the ship is developed and
that's exactly what Magnus does as it is
the top move recommended by the engine
so Bishop to E6 and now you could
capture on B7 first but it's pretty much
the same variation even if you don't
Knight captures an E6 with f characters
and queen captures on B7 uh Rock the C8
and now Castles by nepo uh Queen to D7
and this is magnus's idea okay he's
playing a bit risky but he now wants to
trade queens and he has a strong Center
he has a lot of pieces out uh this is
the the game he wants to play and while
there is a game where Queen captures on
D7 was played here we have Queen to B5
and it is now already as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see uh what Magnus had in mind here he
just continues development Bishop D7 uh
with Bishop to B3 and now castles we
have Queen back to D3 now maybe with
ideas of Shifting the bishop over to
this diagonal to put pressure on
magnus's King side and Knight to A5
attacking the bishop here and well you
could play Bishop to C2 and force G6
nipple decides against it he just plays
Bishop to D1 uh Rook after d8 and now
Bishop to F3 also you could maybe uh put
pressure on that E6 spawn with Bishop to
G4 but just Bishop to F3 for now uh D
captures in C3 Knight captures and
Knight captures and C3 Magnus offers the
queen trade at which nepo accepts with a
queen capture Sun D7 also it's not
forced you could also play some like
Queen at the A6 to put pressure on this
Knight while this Knight is also being
pressured but he just goes for the trade
Queen captures Rook captures and now B
captures on C3 Rook catchers and C3 and
now Bishop the B2 attacking The Rook
hoping to win back the uh extra Pawn
that Magnus has uh but just Rook the C5
Magnus says if you want this Pawn you
will have to fight for it so okay Rook 8
to D1 nipple is down a pawn but he has
the bishop pair the game is on both
sides of the board so of course uh he he
does have compensation Rook captures
only one we have Rook captures and now
Knight the C4 going after the bishop uh
putting Bishop on the back rank um often
proves uh you know to be uh your demise
so just Bishop to C3 now hoping to get
Bishop to B4 in but Magnus throws in a
nice Pawn to E4 the idea behind it is
that if Bishop captures an E4 you play
Knight to D6 attacking the bishop and
this bishop and then you have to settle
for Bishop to B4
after Knight captures on e4 you will
first pressure the Knight and only after
black plays something you will then
capture the real characters captures and
you will have two pieces for The Rook
tonight the pawn is also defended uh so
it's uh you know that at least a better
position for black so after E4 Bishop
the D4 by nepo and now Rook the A5 going
after the A2 pawn and okay they trade
Bishop captures an E4 Rook captures an
A2 Magnus made a good trade here because
he gave up his doubled E Pawn uh for the
a pawn and now he has the outside past
Pawn so Pawn to G3 creating some
breathing room for the white king and
Knight to D2 attacks the bishop with
Bishop to C6 and pawn to A5 Magnus
starts advancing his past a pawn so King
to G2 King to F7 and now Bishop the C3
uh Knight the C4 uh we have rooked D7
putting pressure on the bishop Here and
Now Knight to E3 with checkoff a nice
way to help out with the defense of the
bishop uh King to F3 and now not going
back with Knight to F5 you could also
play this it's very safe but Magnus
throws in a nice Rook to A3 and now
nipple attacks The Rook Rook to B3 and
now uh he kind of has to go for it f
captures an E3 Rook captures on B2
Magnus able to eliminate the bishop pair
and now you're okay up a pawn you've
eliminated the bishop pair so now you
kind of feel that you are better but on
the other hand it's Bishops of opposite
color so even if you're up pawn it will
be very hard to to you know prove a
point here so Rook day seven going after
the outside pass Pawn Rook captures an
H2 Rook captures an E5 and now Pawn to
H5 Magnus preparing to grab more space
here with G5 you're gonna control a lot
of squares in front of the white king if
you do this Rook the A6 now preparing to
put pressure on the E6 spawn and Bishop
to D6 we have Bishop B5 now attacking
the bishop King to E7 defending and
Bishop to C4 and now
uh Magnus has to defend the E6 spawn and
of course he cannot move the bishop but
he has to be very careful here you you
might think okay let's just play Rook to
H3 we capture on G3 with check and it's
game over uh it's game over yes but not
for nepo it will be game over for Magnus
if he did this because now uh Rook
captures on D6 and look at this King
captors and King G2 traps The Rook you
have nothing better than to uh to
capture this and then after a king
captures on G3 okay you do have the two
uh connected pass pawns for the bishop
but it's gonna be very easy to pick them
off let's say G4 or H4 doesn't really
matter King H4 and off goes uh the pawn
next year you're gonna play Bishop to D3
here create a wall against
um uh the the black king pretty much it
so instead after Bishop to C four Magnus
goes for G5 right away uh he cuts off
the white king and now nipple again with
the tricky idea upon the E4 now he is
ready to meet The Rook to H3 with Ponte
E5 and now of course if the bishop moves
then you collect an E6 so Magnus just
goes to C2 attacks the bishop we have
Bishop back to A2 and here nepo had a
sort of a sort of a slightly better idea
I'm just going to show it because it's
super interesting and I know perhaps we
are showing a bit too many lines for a
rapid game but like I said uh they're
not playing rapid silly moves there they
are playing top engine moves pretty much
any move so it would be a shame not to
show it here E5 is the strongest move
because you have to take advantage of
this and now let's say Rook captures on
C4 captures on D6 would check King to D7
and now Rook the A5 uh ready to collect
those pawns and now for example H4 Rook
captures on G5 and now Rook the C3 with
check first king to F4 and Rook captures
sorry Rook captures on G3 and you can't
really trade if you trade everything
captures captures captures and captures
then
uh black is completely winning because
black will get the opposition and of
course the rest is history so what you
will have to do after root captures on
G3 is just move and uh then okay uh you
will you you will fight the save the
game black is better here but you will
uh definitely have chances however I
have to Rook to C2 nepo did not go for
E5 he played Bishop to A2 and now Magnus
plays Rook to C5 uh we have King the E3
Now Pawn to H4 he creates a pass Pawn
captures captures and Rook the A7 with
check with King to F6 Rook the H7
putting the Rook behind the pass pawn
and how does Magnus defend it well Ponte
H3 a very tricky maneuver because now of
course if you capture then just Rook the
C3 check will pick up the The Rook uh so
King to D4 here another tricky move with
Bishop captures and E6 but nepo doesn't
play it right away he first prepares it
with King to D4 uh Rook the C2 and the
bishop captures on E6 now we have Bishop
to E5 check first by Magnus and now King
to D5 the problem is if you go down the
board then Rook the C3 checking the D2
and Dodge's King captures on E6 you're
done a full piece of course the pawn is
now protected
uh so after Bishop D5 check King the D5
was played now comes Rook the D to check
King to C6 and pawn to H2 uh how can
nipple defend against this bishop to G4
Rook F2 Rook to H3 King to G5 and now
okay with Bishop D6 you sort of still
hold if you just move the bishop but
here nipple played Bishop to F3 and now
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Magnus well I'll give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it and I'm sure all of you were able
to do it uh a big congratulations and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is The Rook captures an F3
uh that's of course the move you clear
the H1 Square for the pawn Rook captures
on F3 and now Pawn to H1 with Queen Rook
to F5 with check King to G4 and now Rook
captures on E5 and now of course
everyone knows that Rook against the
queen is completely winning uh what
about a rook against uh queen against a
rook and pawn well of course it's
completely winning it's the exact same
thing only first you have to dispose of
the pawn and you do so by limiting the
movement of the uh white king and the
white Rook so here Magnus made some
moves
uh he he first uh got his queen and king
up the board uh he had to do it uh you
know in a timely Fashion King to D4 then
he gives gave some checks you can do
this uh many different ways uh it's only
important to uh you know really limit
the mobility of white species and now uh
Nepal had to move the pawn that's the
point so this position really because if
you try to sort of keep this Fortress
here uh you you cannot do it if you play
something like Rook D5 because of what
other move can you play uh you have no
squares for your king you have to move
the Rook but then Queen F6 check picks
up the rook and if you don't do this uh
well there's just not much if Rook d8
again Queen tf6 check the king will move
and then uh of course you will attack
The Rook after The Rook moves Queen to
G6 check picks up the pawn and then
Queen and Rook we all know of course is
completely winning so that's why nipple
after King to C6 decided to advance the
pawn there's simply no other way and now
again you limit even more the movement
of the uh white king and Rook so here uh
Rook to G7 Queen F6 check Rook F7 Queen
38 check King to G7 and now King
captures on E6 there was no way to save
the pawn a rook Def One Queen to G5 with
check King to f8 and now Queen to B5
with check nicely uh sorry not with
check just attacks The Rook uh Rook to
F7 and now Queen to H5 attacks The Rook
we have Rook to E7 check King to F6 and
it was in this position and move uh 80
to that uh Yani Pony should resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
uh how are you defending of course these
three scores are covered by the black
king the thread is Queen to h8 Checkmate
and you don't have a way to prolong this
you could play something like Rook to G7
okay now Queen the h8 can be met with
this but now you play Queen H6 and
that's it The Rook falls on the next
move King 8 Queen captures and of course
after King date Queen to B7 you limit
all of the squares only Square available
is the E8 square and once King T8 is
played Queen the E7 or the C8 will be
Checkmate so of course nippo knows this
uh and after this uh a very nice uh uh
move uh he just resigned uh uh sorry he
he just resigned the game uh so yeah uh
very nicely uh very nicely done by
Magnus uh nipple played a brilliant game
but in the end um you know that that one
Pawn was all Magnus needed he was able
to trade his Double E Pawn for that
beautiful past day pawn then when the
past apron became too dangerous he
traded it for the H Pawn and then well
uh here uh there were a couple of
moments where maybe nipple could have
played a little bit better but it was uh
I mean such a complicated game of course
you cannot uh you cannot blame him for
losing this uh but again even though
Magnus won on his board uh his team lost
uh just for those of you who are
interested there you have it uh
uh Magnus one on board one with the
black pieces so he does get more points
but uh abdulsator defeated
during a crush and also but just really
defeated Elizabeth pets but pregnant
that defeated savvani uh also on the on
the
last board with uh with the black pieces
so uh yeah you do get more points for
winning with the black pieces but uh
here it's not enough as uh well that's
eight points and three wins with the
white pieces that's nine points so uh
the the ball and Alaskan Knights have
defeated the Alpine Warriors but it was
a very close call a Magnus and Prague
doing good work with uh with the black
pieces uh so yeah uh that's the game
hope you guys uh enjoyed a bit of a
longer one and we've explored uh a
couple of lines extra uh okay I know it
maybe it's a bit silly for a rapid game
but you've seen how beautiful the lines
were and I could have shown more I mean
that's uh it's a very rich game and I'm
sure that uh when Jan faces the Magnus
regardless of the format uh in in the
tournament he will always bring his a
game but I'm sure Magnus does the same
for every game regardless of who he is
playing uh so yeah I once again really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank an anonymous person dog and Repcon
I've been using uh Thomas veterans
McCormick and James Eugene Cashman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day